П’ять років тому Дмитрові Однойку було 19.
Він навчався на програміста в КПІ. У листопаді 2013,
по суті, кинув навчання, аби піти на Майдан -
протестувати проти рішення Януковича
про відмову від євроінтеграції.
Був тут разом із друзями і в ніч розгону студентів 30 листопада.
Пригадує, що на той момент уже розійшлися всі політики.
Біля стели Незалежності залишалося
кілька сотень людей, переважно студентів.
Коли о 4-ій ранку побачили беркутівців,
думали, що
їх максимум затримають або спробують витіснити з Майдану.
- Вони почали нас просто витискати від стели
і бити всіх, хто потрапляв під руку.
Реально відчувалося, як людей охоплює такий, знаєте, тваринний страх.
Тому що всі почали тікати,
ніхто не знав, що робити. Були в шоці, тому що
за історію сучасної України це вперше,
коли мирний протест, по суті, розганявся кийками
і міліцією настільки жорстоко.
Дмитрові з друзями вдалося втекти.
Вони ховалися на квартирі у знайомого. Тоді ще
було взагалі незрозуміло, наскільки далеко може зайти влада
та чи готові українці продовжити боротьбу за євроінтеграцію.
- Тоді протестний рух проти цього рішення
не підписувати документи по євроінтеграції
він згасав. А  коли відбулося побиття, то люди масово вийшли.
Я навіть пам’ятаю, за оцінками, близько мільйона вийшло першого грудня
через це побиття. Тоді реально почалася Революція Гідності.
Скільки точно було студентів? 200? 400?
Чи ще більше? Хто вони? З яких міст?
Чи змогли вони оговтатися після побоїв, хто їм допомагав?
Що сталося з ними потім? Ці сторінки історії Євромайдану
на тлі подальших, більш трагічних подій,
досі залишаються найменш дослідженими, визнають у Музеї Революції Гідності.
За останні п’ять років співробітникам вдалося
зібрати дуже мало експонатів, пов’язаних саме з першими днями протестів.
- Ось такі стрічки, я пам’ятаю, дуже багато на машини в’язали.
Ознака взагалі перших днів.
А серед сотень інтерв’ю, які були записані
з євромайданівцям, лише зрідка трапляються
розповіді очевидців саме тієї ночі силового розгону студентів.
- Тут є також студенти, які це все зачинали,
розповідають, як вони ходили від вузу до вузу.
Ось Софія розказує цікаво, як вона була кожен день, а в ту ніч саме пішла додому.
- Коли я зранку, мені десь о 5-ій
одразу почали всі надзвонювати, дивлюся ці відео…
Пам’ятаю, я так розплакалася,
тому що зрозуміла, що я настільки причетна до того, що там були люди.
Це був жахливий день. Один з таких перших переломних.
У музеї дуже хотіли би дослідити й інші історії,
приміром, правоохоронців, яких кинули на силовий розгін.
Поки жоден не погодився на інтерв’ю.
Деякі з них поводилися по-людськи,
згадують самі євромайданівці.
- Під час атаки вевешники (співробітники ВВУ - Ред.)...
Не скажу, що саботували свою роботу,
але дозволяли пройти скрізь свої лави,
щоб врятувати від "Беркуту". Це були різні люди.
Дмитру Однойку в ту ніч теж пощастило.
Його кийки та кулаки беркутівців не зачепили.
Він стояв на барикадах Майдану до 18 лютого 2014,
а за три дні до втечі Януковича був поранений
уламками світлошумової гранати, що розірвалася біля його ніг.
Те, що він пережив на Майдані, сильно вплинуло на його життя.
Нині він - активний учасник громадських акцій,
які вимагають тепер уже від нової влади
не допустити реваншу в Україні проросійських сил -
олігархів та політиків із когорти "сім'ї" Януковича.
- Я трохи іноді вірю в долю. Мені здається,
що все рухалося, як мало рухатися.
Я до цього вже почав потроху займатися громадською діяльністю.
Але Майдан на той момент для мене був пік того,
що я міг зробити для своєї країни і для свого народу.
Через 5 років після початку Революції Гідності
Дмитро не може сказати, що повністю
задоволений її результатами.
Каже, в країні сталося багато позитивного,
але й багато негативного. Утім, він переконаний,
що українці рано чи пізно побачать
результати постмайданівських реформ.
Для нього головним результатом революції є те,
що Україна рухається у правильному напрямку - в бік ЄС, а не Росії.